versailles revisités ou comment tu as
château peut nous raconter l'histoire de
france c'est un énorme chantier qui
vient de se conclure 64 salles parmi les
plus belles du palais ont été restaurés
seront maintenant ouverte au public ce
sera dès mercredi dès le 3 d le kart
pardon elle était donc inauguré
aujourd'hui par le ministre de la
culture monsieur léotard ce sont deux
siècles d'histoire à travers la vie
quotidienne de la famille royale al mana
que feuillette maintenant car champetier
et didier rancoeur
personne ne vous en prie pas en plein
jour on pourrait nous voir heureusement
boudoir du petit trianon offrait
certaines commodités secrète et persane
qui était d'humeur badine ne cessez de
faire monter et descendre les murs de
marie-antoinette ce versailles intime
celui des appartements privés et des
petits cabinets de derrière on le
croyait perdu à jamais louis-philippe
n'avait pu écarter les menaces de
destruction qui pesait sur le château
quand le transformant en musée
d'histoire excepté les appartements
royaux et les salons d'apparat
on avait tout cassé pour installer ses
enfilades de salles monotone ouverte de
tableau
par chance on avait gardé l'essentiel
ces plans que l'architecte frédéric
neveu avait fait relever dans les
moindres détails pour garder un souvenir
des appartements condamné et puis les
boiseries splendide authentique qui
dormait dans les réserves depuis le
xviiie siècle
normalement nous aurions dû tout
retrouver vous retrouvons que 50 % à peu
près des boiseries car je pense qu'elles
ont certaines d'entre elles ont été
brûlés pendant l'hiver de 870 71 ou
versailles avec ce transfert dans un
hôpital pour les blessés la guerre
faisait très froid
on a dû brûler des oiseaux un petit
tableau qui représente la galerie des
glaces transformée en salle d'hôpital
via des poils
j'imagine que certaines boiseries sont
passés dans ses poils le résultat après
sept ans de travaux
le voici éblouissant
pour être chaussés de plain pied avec
les fleurs et les i d'eau fraîche
lumineux souriante 38 salles reconstitué
à l'identique
les boudoirs les bibliothèques les
petits salons les cabinets de repos où
le dauphin s'ennuyait avec la dauphine
ou mademoiselle victoire et mademoiselle
adélaïde prix de 8,15 se gaver de
gâteaux et de chocolat avant d'aller
taper sur le cloud
mieux que la chambre du roi ou la
galerie des glaces il évoque le
versailles habité celui de la vie
quotidienne tout aussi luxueux que
l'autre les avec en plus une petite
touche de confort bourgeois qui nous le
rend plus sensible pour les sportifs
signalons encore l'ouverture d'un coup
des 150 salles rajeuni du musée
d'histoire
elle était fermée depuis 20 ans civile
tableau 2000 sculptures les batailles
les grands hommes
les reliques mais le plus étonnant c'est
bien l'escalier de gabriel l'architecte
du roi jusqu'à aujourd'hui il n'existait
que sur le papier à l'état de plans
marie antoinette avait fait interrompre
les travaux pour installer un théâtre
dans la carte
la république terminant l'ouvragé des
rois ça c'est ce qu'on appelle de la
restauration